So you're fast.
Oh, yeah.
Real fast.
heheheh
Whoosh!
Well,
if the fate of the world
ever comes down to
who can win a
500 yard dash,
I have your number
on speed dial.
Ohhh
heh heh heh
ha ha ha ha
I actually like that.
OHHH!!
Whoopsie daisy.
HA HA HA HA HA
Joker!
Sorry.
Look at us.
I have you.
And you've got
none of your
super friends
here to save you because, uh
you fired em all.
So uhh
looks like it's time
to say goodbye.
Oh, wait
Maybe
there's something
you want.
What?
What do I want?
Uhhh
let's see.
How about we take
off that mask
and reveal your identity
on TikTok?
Or how about I drive
your little tank car
into a preschool?
The possibilities are so
FUN!!
HA HA HA HA HA HA HA
You're sick, Joker.
Yeah,
I am sick.
What else do
you expect
from a man
whose
raised by a narcissistic
mother who let
her abusive boyfriend
beat her sweet
little son?
That's me.
Only for that
trauma to manifest
into a disorder
where he laughs
uncontrollably
at Inappropriate
moments
HA HA HA HA
like that.
Hold on.
What?
What do you mean, what?
That’s why you laugh?
It's a medical
condition?
Yes.
I thought you were just
insane and maniacal.
Yeah.
No, it's,
*cough*
It's just a disorder.
The Zoloft helps.
Zoloft, helps?
Yeah,
but you know what was maniacal
those THUGS
who stole my sign
from my sign
spinning job.
You were a sign
spinner?
It was a soulless job
and THAT
turned me into the
homicidal maniac
you see
sitting before you.
Because,
you’re from spinning signs.
Okay, here's
Here's what happened.
Okay,
so the thugs stole my sign.
Yeah, ok
that you were spinning.
And then I chased them
to get my sign.
You gotta get that sign.
And then they beat me up
with the sign.
Okay.
Was it like a
big
heavy
metal sign?
No, it was cardboard.
They hit you with a card,
like a cardboard sign?
Yeah, but it was a really
thick
ply.
Yeah.
You know, like a moving box,
you know what I mean
like an Amazon box,
but really,
you know what I mean?
So you're spinning
a thick ply sign,
and some riff raff
took it,
bopped you with it,
and now you have to
kill kids and sh*t.
Well, the trauma
of the whole sign
spinning incident
twisted my guts,
traumatized me.
Then I started
carrying this gun around,
you know,
to protect myself.
And then it went off
in the children's hospital
and I lost my job
as a clown.
And then...
Hoooooo
Hold.
You worked
as a clown?
hahaha
Well, yeah.
I mean, how else
do you think I can
do this makeup?
Yeah, cause
you could never
just freestyle that.
This is a lot for me.
It's like finding out
Scarecrow was Scarecrow
because
he played Scarecrow
in a production
of The Wizard of Oz.
Just f**kin kill me.
I'm sorry.
F**kin kill me.
Shoot for the mouth hole.
You want me
to shoot you?
Yeah.
Why?
Cause the more
I learned about you,
the lamer you get.
And I'm getting lame
by association.
IT’S WAY
COOLER THAN THAT!
Is it?
YES!!
Let's go flop shoes.
Okay.
I got one for you.
You know what’s
really, really devious?
Please.
Something.
Give me some.
How about this?
I dated my girlfriend
for a whole six months,
and then,
I found out
she was imaginary.
Isn’t that cool?
I just.
I just want to be
very well
heard on this point.
Eat f**kin sh*t.
Sorry.
Eat f**kin sh*t
you clown car, valet.
NOTHING
was better than this.
Me just,
falling asleep,
WONDERING
why you might be
the way you are.
Is better
Then this bullsh*t
Lifetime movie
that I being forced
to sit through.
You’re not TAXI DRIVER
You’re MUST LOVE DOGS.
OKAY!
ALRIGHT!
How about this?
Please.
This is some really
twisted stuff.
I want
to believe.
Here it comes.
Before I was the Joker.
Yeah.
All I wanted to do
was make
people laugh.
This is good.
This is on brand.
And so,
I became
a stand up comedian.
You were an open mic-er?
So I did some open mics
and I did some bringer shows.
Three drink minimums,
that kind of thing.
And then I got
on late night,
and the host mocked me
on the air,
on national television.
HA HA HA
It sounds like you just bombed
Yeah, no, I didn't bomb.
I just.
They didn't get
how funny I was.
So, I shot the host in the face.
Most comics just,
you know,
retreat into improv.
Okay, uh well,
when I didn't kill,
I killed.
HA HA HA HA HA
Ohhh, God.
We deserve better.
Gotham deserves better.
Puns?
Come on, kill me.
You hack!
Alright, STOP!!!
I'M NOT A HACK!!
I’m not a hack.
**music playing**
What, what
what?
What?
**music playing**
What is this?
Are you doing the Elaine?
It's my dance.
It's a
physical manifestation of the
stepping into my.
Stepping into my
new life of evil.
Well, I didn't know
you do
interpretive dance.
You you you are cool.
**music stops**
Really?
NO!
What the f*ck is this?
BumpityBoo’s vlog?
You’re lame.
Hey, shut up!
WE LIVE IN A SOCIETY!
Oh, great.
Your greatest
contribution.
A meme no one gets.
You're gonna die
worse than the
ERMAHGERD GERSBERMS girl.
F*ck this, I quit.
I
PREFER
JARED LETO.